[Musique]
on est volé à la Bourse comme on est tué
à la guerre par des gens qu'on ne
connaît pas un dictateur qui Meur c'est
une banque suisse qui ferme comme dit
Jul renard l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur
rendez-le comme dit préver avec mon
salaire il se P ma tête quelle est la
différence entre un accident et un
banquier si le banquier se noir c'est un
accident SAU catastrophe alors comme le
dit trist Bernard on prête cor on a bien
raison parce que les autres remboursent
difficilement
comprqu c'est l'argent qui travaille le
plus qui est le plus grand
voleur celui qui vole une banque ou
celui qui en ouvre une votre argent
m'intéresse le résultat des
courses ça va faire mal en Bour
[Musique]